hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to lift Lake Garry's Mod
scary Maps I'm here with yamimash hello
everyone I'm yummy nice hello that's my
math show we're playing this and we
definitely didn't have any problems
before he started so here there's all
this cool stuff going on I am NOT being
sane I've seen them it's your fault
running out I do I didn't kill this
person by the way when you weren't
looking well if it wasn't racist I might
just blame you for that but no I won't
we're moving Morgan Freeman by the way
yeah that's Morgan Freeman so yeah we're
coming in here and then there's these
mysterious numbers on the walls
what does these mean what does it mean
we don't know but curiosity kills so
don't think about hey one of the much
you can go first hey I went first last
time I mean I know none nothing ever
happened last time
yeah it's cuz I'm black hey there's a
code there's a keypad back there I think
I gotta feed you some numbers alright
you ready ok 0 3 6 9
try that one yeah 0 3 6 9 that work wait
no listen
2 7 3 8 let's see 7 and then 3 8 that
work ok no ok 0 7 - 8 try that one this
is a joke you okay there you doing okay
there okay good just run around to
crouch before that ceiling about every
button cuz this isn't way no try these
goods I'm trying to help you man you can
can't go and say I have to be in here
five nine or five away it's wait eight
nine zero one
try that one I bet that one's the one
Sierra oh I was good I bet that was it
ah you were so close man why did I die
uh did you not look up what was it bub
oh really
really okay it's a seat I don't know
what happens if you die do you respawn
oh hi hello I'm back hey hey well man
who's what do you got in this time well
I don't see why we need to go in at all
there's kind of another hallway here
yeah this why did we go in there cuz
curio
no sir what was that that was a shadow
oh man oh oh no well we have to just use
crowbars yeah just crowbars okay he's in
this door I don't like it when they're
this looks like a trap oh wise words for
markiplier this looks like a trap hop
balls okay I'm coming sprinting spread
tank sprinting I forgot in half-life 2
you can run really quickly
oh yeah oh he's watching ha made it
alright I'm coming
i'ma come in just jumping around okay
alright so I don't see any hey look it's
my loads get all right there are over
half of his body gun I don't know it
just seems like to bottom like this it's
basically you on the floor yeah okay so
there's nothing here it's the point of
this room what's the point of you I'm
Morgan Freeman oh that's right sorry
sorry sir Jordan err yeah just listen to
my voice
tell me about Andy Dufresne Oh Andy I
bet he wouldn't last a week in this
place yeah sure but yeah honey call
Allen yeah okay alright this thing's
coming back up I don't know if that
means that we actually have to go in
there but I'm gonna go back see if
there's another way oh this door opened
hey come back here get back here
get over here I'm coming over here not
over there over here in the beginning
where the spawn is [ __ ] is terrible
redoing there you are jeez you have like
you can sprint it ten million miles an
hour
Morgan I know you're old Morgan Freeman
we'll come on okay what's in there ah
come on Oh what the hell you see them
over did you see that oh it's just a
chance
Oh get off shut up you didn't see it
okay you just did you didn't see it okay
this car you go first
thank you very much I don't like this
herb bathroom the turn around now war
can be deadly what Oh what
this is behind me okay
uh-oh God is all one pull it in hit man
I don't see any water this is what you
don't have a shower in place you goes
turn on one of those oh oh oh oh come on
why did I follow you in here come on
oh [ __ ] how about your job how ha ha ha
ha ha what a loser
ha ha jamot well at least you're outside
I'm still strapped in here oh oh oh uh
uh uh uh uh oh good its top dog good the
water stopped can you can you let me out
of here come can you help me you know
but on or anything can you I hear that
hey let me tap on the walls you hear me
huh behind the wall
anything anything yet no nothing yet oh
okay
alright well then wait the waters waters
almost gone so I assume when the water
goes down you'll be a big hey hi good
buddy
why don't we listen to these messages
they seem to be I know what's going on
you know this time gonna actually read
them and do what they say okay you first
are you from you see what I see okay I'm
gonna turn around so I don't see
anything that you sees oh good so we all
right no I've got a point the camera oh
I'll go first
your big whip huh all right whoo hello
well that's a lot of technical equipment
right there
Oh strange for a haunted house to have
this sort of stuff rocks and stuff
hey oh they were watching us die in that
room or you die ah I did just fine pull
and then they just booked in they're
gone yeah what about you losers let's
bash let's break their stuff man ha ha
ha huh look out I thrust a grenade
Rajon ha ha ha ha did that hurt you
oh I'm sorry ok let's go back home did
home doom hmm alright these crowbars are
totally ineffective shut up
it's not like we need to kill anything
I'm taking a seat right here and I ain't
moving okay it's just you now okay well
fine I'll go
oh hey this open back here oh oh why do
I have to find all the ways whoa poor
fee and you got any kids and not going
that way
oh that's it there's apparently that's
it that's it we're done
yep does it define a longer one for the
next one hahaha I mean besides that what
jokes care there's more fun than
anything nice treat it
mock why why who did that hot Wow [ __ ]
smack god dammit why I played a lot of
half-life deathmatch in my time you just
aren't made this video last longer
Yeah right on I'm trapped oh I'm sorry
Morgan free very funny
hey why is my Skype ringing ah ah stop
bringing me on skype you awesome who's
calling you
that's one of my friends thanks Brett my
god ghost it's a ghost
oh no I'm reloading my please don't kill
me how do you throw a grenade you don't
I do okay I got a pistol no you don't
your pistol can't do anything oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
oh I'm shocked gonna do some modeling
yeah it's super effective I bet hey
what's going on anyways here
here we go ahead come on noise hahahaha
ah you got me
sonica [ __ ] okay alright
the truth okay truce okay I want to use
this real quick yeah I got like what is
this this is not what no you gotta hit
objects and get him to move ah say this
is pretty cool actually yeah it is
psychedelic even this ya know I mean I
don't know I wish I hope it does okay
where'd you go you mean ask my now go
dogs bye
you let go that's mine hey how are you
guys mine get out get out hey that's
mine even up in the [ __ ] ha ha what
happened everything oh I took the door
all right off the hinges
her cha-cha crowd wonder if I can take
these joint vaults off the earth the
walls are down no no no not there
anymore
hey the computer give me the computer oh
you doing what nothing
what what do you think I was doing
trying to kill me no course not that's
before you have a truce now yeah whoa
hello hey I got the regular gravity gun
here
hey how do you do that it's a gravity
gun
Boosh ha ha ha oh my ha ha ha ha I'm not
disabled huh
no oh right and I'm not moving well that
makes it easy to find you don't miss me
alright I'll fight off enough of you
kill right cause you're friends now you
can kill me you can kill ok
Hey look wait what's this whoa whoa whoa
stop hey stop that man him don't move
this doesn't hurt trust me it does not
hurt I think it would not gonna hurt you
hey I gotta try this yeah uh-uh I have a
camera I can take a nice picture of you
say cheese man yeah no hang on
hey I want a picture you I got aa goth
okay smile why at nice complexion you
got there there we go I took a pic we
reviewed it sir number 6 I took an ice
pick right now I have all good
Oh Oh if you get to stop it you give him
stop that sorry
hey yeah Texas right [ __ ] I just got
boobs everywhere yeah I know I did too
it's is it this is a good I don't even
know what we're doing but in this time
that we've been [ __ ] around we could
have loaded up another map or something
but I choose to dick around until we
crash the server there's so many room
I'm going through the duel by I don't
think that's anymore that's how that
door
we're talking about it's just you and me
man
just you and me I think I've got you on
the ropes Oh God oh man wait hang on
yeah one second why why is what what are
you doing how are you doing my god one
second how do you do this i crash
through the server yet no not yeah well
attach ropes to everything and I'm gonna
get thrusters on them try to get over to
a you are but okay now I'm glitching hmm
came here mmm
where's the thrusters I know there's
dusters in this somewhere ah ha ha ha ha
here again oh oh [ __ ] how do I make them
go oh hey I was using that through you
buddy you know I I've had it up to here
with your bull don't kill me okay Oh Oh
was that don't kill me ah tube back oh
hey I know doc ally shoot these things I
was gotta get thrusters out everything
okay anyway all right that's enough
silliness I think that's enough all
right so thank you everybody so much for
watching check out yamimash a channel
for an actual longer scary map where we
don't devolve into silliness so thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for videos that i've done and
as always we will see you in the next
video bye bye
ah
Oh